[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome to the Lobby
gamespot's weekly hangout here at 2PM
Pacific from San Francisco California
it's our first time on in three weeks so
I'm back hosting this week Pete Brown is
still out but Rob Handler we got you
here you're gonna be on the whole day
we've got a lot of stuff to talk about
yeah thanks for having me yeah it's
great to be here with you great to have
you on as always and Eric Tay who's
usually behind the scenes but every once
in a while comes on to lend us some
expertise about a shooter here and there
sometimes yeah we're uh we've got a full
show today we're gonna go through a few
things we got a few like weird kind of
things we're gonna do by like historical
games with Mafia because we've already
talked Mafia to death um I'm gonna have
Scott on and there's no more like not
much more point in talking about the
review anymore because we did like a
couple updates but we're going to talk
about kind of like period piece games in
general uh Call of Duty beta we're all
playing a lot of games right now I'm not
like a lot we can't talk about yet but a
lot coming up but anyway yeah it's a
full show Rob Handler did you get the
chance to play the Call of Duty beta at
all no uh I did not unfortunately but I
did get to comb through a lot of footage
of uh Eric Tay over here playing it
um I'm more are
into your guys's opinions I mean
you know how it plays is something
completely different than from what I've
seen but it looks like you know it looks
like cod yeah I mean it's it's weird
because it's Infinity War the last game
they released was ghosts and that was
kind of following the whole thing with a
respawn farming with Vince impella Jason
West and Grant Collier left and uh so
this could you know theoretically be
their first game to put them back on the
map like I'm sure that's what they're
hoping because ghost was kind of not
received all that well the multiplayer
was a little bit stale the campaign same
thing but uh so this is the first chance
the I think tomorrow it goes wide to the
public on PS4 it's either tomorrow or
today but right now it's closed beta um
and you and I played we streamed it
yesterday Eric uh what do you what are
your overall thoughts so far how does it
feel uh much to what Rob said it's kind
of like another Cod there are like
little layers of differences I guess
like the the double jump wall running
stuff they kind of had already
um in advanced Warfare
um so they're kind of like tweaking that
like a little bit
um and then now there's rigs instead of
Specialists like in Black Ops 3 so
there's a little bit more to that kind
of um game player that system that
they've they've kind of gone with so
every rig has like you know three
payloads or two or three payloads which
is kind of like a
I know Peter's gonna hate me for saying
this but it's like a special ability
ultimately like an ultimate even though
they're called payloads and then they
all have traits of which do different
things so each character does different
things
um and certain abilities will probably
play better for certain like game types
and whatnot so uh it's just I guess
another extra layer but it's not that
different and then the the weapons you
can craft them
now which is slightly different or get
them in boxes which uh you do like
quests or just log in Daily and you get
keys and you open them and you just hope
to God you get a epic I guess which The
Loot Crate system is kind of pervasive
in Shooters now I mean OverWatch has had
a big deal it was like the aesthetic the
skins and the the emotes and whatnot
earlier this year
um Titanfall I'm not sure what they're
gonna have yet battle Battlefield 1 has
the Battle Packs that's very similar you
get skins you get new weapons and that's
kind of become this thing where it's
almost a gamble right I mean obviously
you don't have to spend real real money
if you don't want to but it's kind of
like the more time you invest the more
chance you have it getting whatever you
want I guess
um did we get anything I got an epic so
it's like uh it's kind of like the
traditional like Diablo Destiny loot
it's like a blue weapon purple and then
orange or the epics I got an epic for a
weapon and then I didn't actually have
the weapon itself unlocked until like
level 20 or something yeah so it didn't
matter at least in the beta I didn't I
don't know if that's going to change but
you also have these factions right or
what they call the mission teams yeah so
there's like the wolver Marines as other
factions can you explain how those work
um so I didn't go too in depth with them
but it just seems like they're kind of
like your faction that you uh like
Pledge Your Allegiance to so to speak uh
you get missions from him to do certain
objectives within the game that you're
playing so it's like head shots or like
double kills or
um you know payload kills or something
like that and every time you do that you
slowly love like so you have two things
you're leveling right you're leveling
your core level which allows you to
access more guns and and gear and stuff
like that as well as the rigs and then
you have kind of your faction which uh
also unlocks like guns and stuff like
that so and I think he gives you keys
and Salvage and materials and stuff like
that so it's just kind of getting you to
do all these little extra like almost
like bounties like in Destiny so it's
like oh while you're playing the game
try to get headshots you get headshots
you'll level up your faction reputation
and you'll get benefits from it kind of
a little layer it's like they just added
even more layers to the progression like
every single shooter does now I think
like maybe not every single but a lot of
the military Shooters do that right now
you have Mission teams worry about you
have the legendary weapons and the
crafting to think about uh you have just
these I mean obviously you're unliking
things like call signs and whatnot but
you have like aesthetic things for your
uh the different rigs so the rigs not to
keep like pointing out hero shooters or
mobiles but like it's that's kind of
becoming a thing because Titanfall 2 has
the mech or the Titans themselves are
like characters now with superpowers
rather than a heavy or light with
specific loadouts that people are going
to go for but we can get into that like
probably next week more with Titanfall 2
but it is it's kind of this ubiquitous
thing now where the the hero Shooter's
kind of invading military Shooters now
because like the rigs like specialists
in Black Ops 3 were kind of the uh the
Inception of this idea with Call of Duty
right you had these different characters
that you could recognize them and know
that Sparrow's Longbow is pretty
dangerous uh if you see the sonar pulse
you know she's kind of like picking out
people with radar and whatnot it's not
only about how you play those characters
about how to know how to counter them
have you found that to be pretty deep in
the beta so far
um I didn't notice it as much as like
you would like in OverWatch but I mean
obviously when you see someone have
their payload out especially if it's
like a weapon type like based one You
definitely want to try to kill them as
fast as possible or run away or try to
get to a spot where like your team can
Team fire them sure so like you know if
uh snap is it synaptic or snap I always
synaptic synaptic uh he can go into that
like kind of robot dog mode right where
he he basically can wall wall run or run
on the ground and then he won one shots
you with melee but he has to get pretty
close to you to do that so like if you
can get away or use some of the movement
mechanics that are in the game to get
away and then hopefully
um there's some of that I guess but in
terms of like hard countering some stuff
I I haven't seen it but if you read some
of the tool tips they do say hey this
it's like certain traits and stuff like
that will like hard count or something
else I haven't seen it in terms of like
the payloads necessarily but I'm sure
like if you're FTL if you have like
essentially like the Golden Gun right
like if you see a racer yeah sorry
eraser if you see you know someone else
with you know the the steel Warhead or
whatever like you can just shoot them
and like that's how you deny it's kind
of how it was in Black Ops 3 in a way
too I think one thing like a lot of
people are curious about I don't know
how much you've seen it yet Rob but I
think people saw that they said they
might be like using the low gravity in
cool ways or multiplayer at least we
hoped they would but now right now on
the uh what's the map that's close
quarters Frontier it's like this these
hallways and sight lines and I like the
map because it's cool how like it kind
of folds in on itself underneath certain
hallways but it's this spaceship hallway
and like every time someone dies they
just float into the air but that seemed
to be the case for a lot of the maps oh
but my actually my question was going to
be are different Maps like do they have
different like forms of gravity or or
heightened gravity in some of them
because it felt like every time you were
doing a double jump or a floaty jump
it's just it looked like a mannequin was
kind of like
flying around the map it was just a
weird something that's I feel like for a
Cod game I've never seen before like
well it's weird because in this I can't
remember for the life of me in Black Ops
3 did you also have to kind of hold the
Boost button to do the double jump as
opposed to Titans uh tab it twice
because right now you kind of to use up
the whole meter it's like this meter use
up and while running uses it double
jumping uses it sliding a little bit
Black Ops 3 had a little bit more of
like a feather to it like you could you
could kind of get a little more out of
it like you it was a little more
controlled it goes to a hard second jump
because this is nothing this does it too
same thing this right now is you have to
like hold it a little bit to use the
whole double jump and yeah that kind of
worries me because I don't want my thumb
to be there I want it to be on the
analog stick ready to aim at somebody
um I mean because if you just let go
you're not going to do the full height
of your jump and if you need that full
height to Vault over something or get to
this wall to run down it kind of worries
me it's a minor mechanic I'm sure it
wouldn't affect the overall game too
much but it feels good in general same
thing with the the ground Dash you have
to kind of hold your circle or Circle or
uh when you're sprinting and everything
but yeah that's the one thing I haven't
seen this is just the beta the game
um we got one of our editors is
reviewing it right now but obviously he
can't talk about it yet it releases uh
early November but right now it doesn't
seem like they're using the future
aesthetic to make the maps actually
interesting I mean I like the rigs and I
like the idea of those and I like that
they're a little deeper than the
Specialists because the Specialists were
kind of again like the introduction of
that idea they had the mobility and
everything from advanced warfare and
like the earlier Titanfall but right now
I'm not seeing too much creativity like
when I kind of want to at this point
whenever this close to release I don't
know because you have like we're talking
in like a few minutes about which
shooter is right for you coming out this
fall I mean we had doom and OverWatch
and you know battleborn earlier in the
year but now we have like another three
which are all kind of similar like
military Shooters and you know you kind
of have to set yourself apart especially
if you're Call of Duty which releases
every year people are gonna buy it
people are gonna like it I'm sure it's
gonna be it it will probably be decent
from everything I've played so far but I
don't know I kind of was hoping that we
would see more in the beta about them
being creative yeah I mean to your point
it's like we're pretty deep in the game
now so I'm pretty sure like what you saw
in the beta outside of like some like
rig balancing or weapon balancing is
kind of what you're gonna get unless
there's more maps that we haven't seen
which is possible but I mean Frontier is
probably like a decent example of like
where they could have messed with low
grab a little bit and they didn't right
so I don't know if they're gonna
innovate in terms of that in terms of
like maps and stuff like that so I don't
expect that so much but you know it's
another solid CoD game you the shootings
like what it what you would expect you
know no like very little recoil uh
actions really fast you get back in like
really quickly I think that's kind of
part of the Allure of playing Cod I
guess is that like even if you die it's
like I'm gonna go get that guy because I
can respawn like right away whereas you
know like with a battlefield and some of
these games we're going to talk about
later it's a little bit different but
it's definitely interesting time with
like like these three kind of like all
futuristic shooters or well Sans
battlefield but all these shooters
coming out like almost like weeks after
each other yeah to be completely fair I
had fun with Call of Duty I don't know
if I would want to play it past that
level 30 Mark I think is 30 the cap for
the beta 30 is the cap for the beta but
I'm sure there's probably more race and
again there's there's another handful of
maps we don't even have access to right
now
um we're gonna be able to probably see
more get more into the weapon crafting
just because we're playing with
different Mission teams I would assume I
think there's only one unlocked right
now or two there's two okay so yeah I
think there are more than that don't
quote me on that but yeah I'm looking
forward to it and again I'm kind of more
curious about the campaign at this point
um The Campaign is the one thing that
you know they said there's no loading
screens it's just like this seamless
thing there's either you're either
taking off from Earth to space or vice
versa or planet to space I don't know
what planet you go to or it's a cut
scene which sounds cool or you're in
that Hub ship which sounds cool because
if this if it's this kind of I don't
know how they're gonna structure it but
if it's this seamless kind of
thing that you're just playing the whole
time and not just going oh mission three
let's just replay that that sounds like
that could set this game apart from like
Black Ops 3 which had a pretty decent
campaign was my favorite but I'm pretty
curious about single player in this game
or like any Call of Duty game like that
doesn't sound linear at all which is
like totally the Call of Duty experience
yeah and the space combat I haven't
tried yet at all I don't think aside
from people that are like reviewing it
ostensibly I haven't touched that I
don't think anybody has
um but yeah so that is Call of Duty
infinite Warfare the beta I believe is I
think it's either today or tomorrow it's
open for everybody on PS4 and that will
be uh you know like public now it won't
just be closed so more people will be
able to play it go up to level 30 and uh
you guys will get to try it out and uh
let us know what you think in the
comments below
Eric Tay sadly I have to bid you I do
for now yeah where is the next person
though Scott Butterworth is gonna come
on and we're going to talk about there
he is he's gonna touch on Mafia three
again I'm gonna let him in yeah go for
that we're gonna touch on Mafia three
again uh he's talked that Game of Death
he played a ton of it really good review
is up uh we can get into it quick like
his score and everything and what he
thought about that but yeah gonna touch
on that briefly and here he comes now
but I don't know Rob what have you been
playing ladies Battlefield yeah
Battlefield uh I'm trying I played a
little bit of um off your three
um that story and the style of the
documentary
um theme just in general like is super
gripping it's great yeah cool yeah so
Mafia three Scott you have talked about
it a fair amount on the lobby already
yeah I think we did like an Ask A
reviewer last week but that was before
the final review went up so finally like
the score and everything's on the site
and that went up what day was it do you
remember last Wednesday last Wednesday
on the show talking about it on Tuesday
and then the final review went up on
Wednesday yeah so we'll talk about the
review briefly because you've already
talked about that but then we want to
throw a curveball and kind of do like
more fun feature like we just want to
talk about historical games in general
period piece games our favorites just
like between I don't know I've got a few
picked out Eleanor Assassin's Creed
games Battlefield 1 might be interesting
to talk about it's obviously they're not
going for realism but it's kind of
that's like the big draw of that game
but anyway so Mafia 3 you gave it a six
out of 10. can you tell us like final
thoughts that you might not have gone
into on the lobby yet or like I mean
overall the I mean the big thing again
is is the score I feel like I I
explained a lot of like my thinking and
what ultimately went into the final
review in fact I think I've even used a
lot of the same language when I was on
the show that eventually made its way
into the review but I mean this is just
one of those situations like I always
say please read the text don't Focus
entirely on the number of scoring that
game was very difficult because it is
such an inconsistent experience I mean
in that the story is so excellent and
the shooting is so like fine and the
technical problems were pretty
persistent
um it's been a mix across the board like
I've seen people in comment sections on
our site and our other sites saying like
I had no you know problems whatsoever
and people saying like oh I could barely
get through a mission without the game
crashing like so it seems to be pretty
inconsistent but but we again tested the
game on all three platforms experienced
hard crashes among other problems on all
three platforms so ultimately when it
came time to score the game and put out
the final review was like okay like we
can confirm that these issues impact
every platform and it's not something we
can Overlook and therefore it's it just
it drags the score down and that's what
sucks about technical issues those are
always sporadic from one person to the
next I know I had some technical issues
with Gears War 4 and other people are
saying that didn't happen at all with me
I was like well that's lucky for you
that made your experience much better
and like I unfortunately did experience
them but it's kind of sporadic but like
from what we've seen Mafia 3 is pretty
much across the board everybody's
noticing big big problems yeah it seems
like the people not having problems are
a lot more rare Than People experiencing
at least some level of technical
difficulty whether they're game breaking
or just something funny like Lucy James
over on our UK office she that she like
kind of did a she slightly nudged that
speedboat did a few barrel rolls and
then launched in the air it was spinning
around and then for about 10 seconds I'm
not exaggerating she was looking up into
the sky to try to find it and then all
of a sudden it just missled her boat and
blew her up yep it was awesome it was so
good oh she yeah she tweeted I think I
don't know how many retweets I think
it's on like our Facebook as well I
think it's on like The Game Spot
Facebook and she definitely tweeted this
like I don't know three or four days ago
it's so good yeah like man one of the
funniest glitches I've seen in a very
long time you should definitely check it
out but for all like for what it's worth
I yeah I played the first 90 minutes of
Mafia 3 I loved I think I played about
five hours total now and from what you
said it's a huge really long game but
already I started to feel like a
repetitive with like a clearing out
rackets and kind of setting up things
with your cohorts and kind of just
shooting a lot of people when I kind of
wanted to be making better use of the
open world than just just driving and
shooting but I do love that setting and
I do love New Orleans I love that they
put so much research into it um you know
they tackle tough stuff like this Rachel
tent racial tension political Strife of
1968 probably the most if not one of the
most turbulent years in American history
um and that was a bold thing to do like
I'm sure there's a lot of different
opinions on whether they succeeded or
not but that's a world I'm going to
remember for a long time and that's kind
of what like what's cool about video
games in certain cases because Mafia 3's
version of New Orleans uh newborn dough
you know it's fictionalized they've
added Hills added tunnels they just like
in general some things about the period
they rework to better fit the game but
that's why I want to talk about just
historical games I guess period piece
would be the film term but I don't know
Rob like there's a little there's a
bunch of games that have gone into like
this kind of using an actual setting to
set a tone or tell a story do you have
any like favorites that come to mind
remember uh showing
like having just got like a PS2 and
showing my I believe I believe it was
medal of honor front line uh and you
know of course like a lot of those Call
of Duty games came out like after Saving
Private Ryan and we're you know that
that movie really changed like how
people visualized uh and not so much
romanticized that that war and man that
like Frontline scene in the beginning
where you're like on the landing craft
just like Private Ryan like planes was
by I remember like seeing that and then
showing like like my mom and she was
like this is incredible we were blown
away like I remember like that for me
was like the height of video games at
that time yeah because that was it was
weird because that was one of the first
games I can remember where you get onto
the beach and your objective wasn't to
shoot somebody it was just to shoot like
suppressing fire I don't know if you
remember right and you you're the rest
of the American troops wouldn't move up
the beach until you just fire your
Thompson up there a little bit and yeah
now that seems normal like in
Battlefield 1 you get suppression
bonuses for just shooting in an enemy's
direction if they're behind cover but
yeah I remember that was just straight
out of Saving Private Ryan like that
intro scene that um Hanks and Spielberg
and everybody worked on it was just
unreal and it did definitely set a tone
because later on it gets more into the
Espionage stuff right you're kind of
like a covert Soldier later on you go on
to like German U-boats to sabotage their
supplies and whatnot but yeah I don't
know but like I wonder how much research
went into that game as far as like
making it historically accurate totally
I had a similar experience with Allied
assault which also depicted the storm in
the beach at Normandy and just yeah like
so much stuff happening around you which
at the time was pretty new like shooter
campaigns were very like hey you're in a
room there's some guys ahead of you run
and shoot and keep going and whatever
this was very much like no no you're
participating you're just one small Cog
in this much larger battle and there's
stuff blowing up around you people dying
around you just seeing that and being
immersed in that was very new and very
like spectacular for the time and yeah I
mean it is cool just to be sort of very
I hate the word but viscerally
experiencing a piece of History like
that to know that like this is a
recreation of something that actually
happened I mean if we're talking about
historical periods and period pieces and
games and clearly World War II is one of
the most like you know deeply mind
sources of history for you know material
and and I think that I mean as you
mentioned we've covered a lot of
different aspects of that war and a lot
of different in interesting ways yeah
and I remember I think Call of Duty 2
came along that was my first Xbox 360
game and that instead of storming so
it's Omaha Beach in uh in medal of honor
front line Allied so I believe it's
Omaha Beach too but then like Utah Beach
was the one that we stormed to link up
with the 101st infantry after they drop
Behind Enemy Lines the night before
Point du Hawk and Call of Duty 2 when
the Rangers were scaling those Cliffs uh
so I read a pretty extensive account of
it like I forget what book it was I
think it was citizen soldiers Steven
Ambrose who wrote Banner Brothers also
wrote citizen soldiers and they were
scaling these Cliffs to take out these
like anti-navel guns I think and then
they got there the Germans already moved
them so intel was bad but like that was
also unreal because again and that was
my first 360 game so that like
each time I play like a newer game
obviously Frontline isn't going to look
good right now but then you get like it
doesn't it's Call of Duty two which
doesn't even look that great now but at
the time it was like this is unreal yeah
and you know it's weird because like now
we have Battlefield one come around and
that was a big thing like I have how
much of the campaign have you played I
actually played a good amount uh I've
been kind of holding back for the PC and
I finally kind of got into that uh
played like that kind of like that um I
suppose it's just like the intro of the
game prologue the prologue yeah
that was super uncomfortable
people scream like we when we did the
stream the other day and playing the
operations mode if you've seen it at all
Scott but like there's a lot more
narrative but I would say there's a lot
more like emotion like there are people
blowing that whistle and then just
tons of people just screaming and
charging there is something extremely
unsettling about like playing at game
one it looks freaking unreal and just
shooting people it feels extremely
uncomfortable compared to like I don't
know I made it you want to compare it to
like Frontline like we said but there's
something about how it looks the mud
knowing about World War One compared to
World War II like yeah it's it was not
nearly as like in a lot of ways black
versus white yeah and uh that was the
thing about I remember like now that
you're talking about it there's that
scene from like
um Enemy at the gates that we were
talking about it was in Call of Duty
finest Hour when you're running across
um red square and Stalingrad and then
you got one guy with a rifle one guy
with a bandolier in case he dies like
you pick it up and shoot and that's kind
of the same thing Battlefield 1 from
what I've played of the campaign but
little I've played and from multiplayer
the operations mode we were just talking
about it's the story driven like kind of
I guess pertinent to this conversation
it's that story driven what would have
happened if the Germans defended this
um in the Italian Alps and you know like
the uh you know the US actually pushed
them back or what if the US actually
failed and there is much more impact to
Battlefield one and you know frostbite
engine helps like like having that like
the condensation on the guns the mud on
your gun when you go prone to get back
up it creates a better sense of place
again these are like Maps designed to be
fun in the end and they are kind of
they're trying to shed light on these
like lesser known historical accounts
did campaign do that much farther in
like I know one is Lawrence of Arabia
one is uh there's like a there's an
Italian
um he's like a heavy Trooper right and
he's telling his granddaughter's telling
a story from his point of view yeah I
haven't gotten that far enough okay yeah
and anyway like that game itself kind of
I like that they actually I know uh
Miguel Concepcion we're gonna have him
come on and talk more about his review
in a few minutes but he was saying
there's a lot it's Bleak the campaign
yeah he said it almost feels ham-fisted
but then when you look at it maybe it
should because World War one it was the
war that like called it the Great War
because we didn't know anything like
that would ever happen again but I don't
know to get away from the more
depressing side of the games uh Ellie
Noir is one of my I that game is so
flawed in so many ways and especially
the core mechanics I don't know if you
you guys play Ellie Noir oh yeah it did
not need to be an open world game no not
at all like because the conversation's
been a cool thing and then but the
setting like that uh just La in the 50s
reminds me of like um I don't know just
like a ton of movies are set there um
L.A confidential is one of my favorite
movies and it nails that like the way
that everybody dresses the facial
animation capture helped but I remember
that just every time I talk to somebody
their accents a lot of people from Mad
Men were in the show the main character
in La noires Ken Cosgrove from Mad Men
yeah
um but I don't know what did you think
of you said it didn't need to be open
world why do you think that you should
like more linear would you have
preferred well because it was basically
an adventure game that for whatever
reason was set in an open world it
didn't really make sense I mean the game
was all about you know acting as a
detective in classic Los Angeles right
in vintage la
there was no reason to like include
driving and shooting and that really I
mean there was all this attention paid
to like you know the voice acting and
facial capture as you mentioned was at
the time was pretty revolutionary even
if it looks a little bit wonky and
bizarre now
um so it's weird to me that they would
invest all those resources in that
aspect of the game and this really
unique and interesting aspect of the
game and then shoehorn that into this
open world structure I mean from what I
remember that game had a pretty tortured
development cycle and or uh whatever uh
people suspect that Rockstar was kind of
like pressuring team Bandai to finish
the project and and they were not happy
with how things were turning out and
that may have directed certain design
decisions and that might be why the game
turned out the way it did but yeah I
mean the sections for me of that game
they're most memorable are always like
the interrogations or the investigation
investigative portion of the game I
don't remember any of the driving or
shooting like that was all completely
unnecessary to like the core experience
in my mind but they're pretty right yeah
the city was really cool and it's really
interesting to go to La and see what
remains of that time period because
there are still traces of that in in Los
Angeles there's not much of it but if
you go to like Broadway if you go to Old
like East L.A like what used to be
downtown you can still see like art deco
buildings and like traces of this
architecture that's still around even if
much of the city has kind of moved on
and forgotten that portion of its past
yeah it's always interesting to see
these like vestigial things like that
have remained since the past like I
don't know like New York City has a ton
of that still like San Francisco you
know like different a weird like
Smorgasbord of different kind of
architectural Styles and everything but
it's that kind of leads me to Max one
the Assassin's Creed series you know
like they were yearly for a while or by
like bi-annual
um depending on who was developing them
they're all under UB stuff but like you
know which studio Ubisoft but you know
that was always the Allure of what was
the next Assassin's Creed game where was
it gonna be set the first one was pretty
cool because like I think I mean we
didn't know what the series was when the
first one was announced but then the
next one comes along it's Renaissance
Italy and people were asking for like
Japan like feudal Japan for the entire
series and I wouldn't be surprised they
still came back and did that but these
games are always cool like the amount of
research that Ubisoft did put into like
checking these cities out obviously
again they took creative liberties with
making them fun and like making it fun
for like SEO and alter air to scale but
I don't know my my favorite Assassin's
Creed was always Assassin's Creed
Brotherhood which took the Italian
setting and then just like focused on
Rome but of course like because of
gameplay things it was my favorite with
the actual overarching training or
Assassins but in terms of just like the
setting like that was awesome like you
get to it's really like stylized you go
Leonardo for like inventions and whatnot
that can help you fight people but I
don't know did you have you like had a
lot of experience with Assassin Creed
games uh the second one was where I got
pulled in where like is that going to
where it's at yeah I mean it was where
it was where I was enjoying the open
world of it like hitting the rooftops
and all and all that stuff
um
yeah definitely that's that's my
favorite one I think you know uh the
third one was was cool like man was the
the level of excitement I had for three
was so high like oh man he's got a
hatchet like you know like Patriot like
just the movie you just you have all
these ideas of what that game could have
been but uh that game was just loaded
with bugs and that was where I where I
lost well and also every Mission Giver
gave you the exact same speech of like
war is difficult people don't understand
that was literally everyone's like okay
we get it through his wooden teeth
Shades of Gray fine yeah whatever uh
yeah oh that trailer there yeah the uh
it was always I mean I'm I'm a sucker
for like that setting just like you said
um like Revolutionary War era uh and
then like Conor I forget how you
pronounce it like actual given name rag
ragui McGregor O'Connor McGregor but
yeah a UFC fighter in Assassin's Creed
Three uh that's a weird reference Scott
thanks it's the only Conor you know it's
Conor McGregor uh that was the first one
that came to mind man all right I had to
make the joke quicker I love it um yeah
so then like he comes along and he seems
cool but then like I didn't like how he
was written I thought he was kind of a
baby in a lot of ways he's got a
brooding and yeah and understandably so
but it's also just like if you're with
that character for 20 hours eventually
you're just like all right dude you
really need to like shut the hell up
yeah and then they just like started
like forcing that um that colonies board
game stuff into it um the homestead
stuff which I didn't think was great
that's when like the naval stuff and
that's what's so funny was the naval
stuff and then where it was like what
and just to have Black Flag wasn't after
that yeah it was it was my like now that
I think about it like Assassin's Creed 2
brother has my favorite Assassin's Creed
game but like black uh Black Flag I
still have the urge to go back and
pledge because not for the parts that
were felt like Assassin's Creed just for
the sailing and being a pirate and you
unlock you find those pages so your crew
can sing those different songs there's a
weird name for them and then they're
just singing like yo ho Yoho and then
you just flying over the waves like
smoking these gigantic ships uh it's
gorgeous that was one of my first PS4
games after Call of Duty ghosts
um and that series like I mean it's so
weird to have this year that we don't
have an Assassin's Creed Syndicate last
year in uh Industrial Revolution kind of
turn of the century London I didn't play
much unfortunately
um maybe I will at some point yeah but
serious has covered a lot of ground
though I mean especially if you're
including like graphic novels and other
stuff like in that same universe I think
there was I'm fairly confident there was
a comic book set in feudal Japan based
in the Assassin's Creed Universe okay
and there may have also been like one of
the side-scrolling games I'm trying to
remember what that sort of sub series
was called well there's three of them
right yeah there's there's three one set
in Russia one I believe was China Japan
or maybe it was China Chronicles China
Chronicles yeah I didn't play any of the
Chronicles games so I only have a dim
recollection of this unfortunately but
regardless yes I mean if we're talking
about historical games Assassin's Creed
it's like covered more ground than just
about any other franchise yeah it seemed
like a printing conversation we have uh
Battlefield one it was a big deal
because not going futuristic like
Titanfall and infinite Warfare and like
Black Ops 3 did last year uh it's just
one of those military shooters that kind
of broke the mold by going back to
something that has already been done to
death or not World War one but that kind
of uh you know like 20th century War era
um and don't forget sieves out at the
end of the week which encompasses all of
history exactly really Civ uh I've
played a fair amount of save with my
preview build and I know you're
reviewing right now we can't talk about
the review build too much when I played
the preview yeah it's just like you get
like really cool stories out of like
twists on History like I know the one
thing that um
uh for axis and 2K actually don't like
to talk about it but apparently
um Gandhi's estate like doesn't like
when people bring up civilization this
the video game series like Gandhi his
like his like estate does not like it
because there's that one glitch where
his personality would go so far into the
negative like on the good side that it
would Circle back to the max aggressive
and he would just nuke everyone
it's super funny not sure we're supposed
to be talking about it now but they
don't like when you like when
civilization is brought up in relation
to Gandhi because of that glitch but
yeah
so great so this was never enough to
happen but yeah like it was just some
weird program thing where he could
become so peaceful yeah that it would
loop around and yeah just become like
the ultimate he would just attack
everyone it sounds like a robot if you
look up like YouTube videos to people
with like combating Gandhi and civ5 it's
hilarious yeah it's like I said like
Civilization that's one of my favorite
that's one of the reasons like some of
my it's my favorite series you get that
like weird Twist on history based on
like these real people in real places
but yeah those dudes know their history
throughout these guys are like big
history Buffs yeah those weird twists
where Gandhi had a bunch of new yeah but
anyway so that is our discussion on
historical video games period pieces uh
what do you think let us know in the
comments below what games you have
played that set a good tone kind of
paint a location in favorable ways
all right moving on to more
pressing things I guess
um we have played the Call of Duty beta
we have our review for Battlefield 1 is
up we're gonna talk about that in the
next segment when Miguel comes out and
talk about his review and Titanfall 2
rob you and I have played a lot we can't
you've played a lot of preview uh yeah
so we're gonna talk about kind of there
were two shooters or three Shooters are
in the air between battleborn doom and
OverWatch but we kind of covered those
uh maybe at the end of the year we're
gonna do a wrap up like which was the
best shoot of the year or something I
don't know but right now we want to do
like if you have to get one shooter this
fall which one is for you not saying you
have to you can get all three that would
be great too because Infinity Ward Dice
and respawn are all great developers and
I've had fun with all these games so far
um but I kind of wanted to touch on like
the differences I don't like I think
we're all probably gonna I don't know
that we're all gonna pick one
individually but I mean we don't have to
pick one but I kind of just discuss it
for people watching like which one's for
you let's just start with Battlefield
one because it was the first one they
released on the 21st rob you are
enjoying this game a lot and I think a
lot of people are yeah I mean it's
it's got kind of everything I want and
again having like grown up with 1942 and
being like obsessed with that game like
I was in a a stupid ass clan we didn't
win a single match in that Clan but I
was obsessed with it and this is
exciting for me like I remember when
this was released or announced uh that
it was gonna be World War one I remember
being like Oh I wanted World War II but
this is ultimately World War II I mean
it's got the heart and soul of that
original game
um you know seeing this game take on
different fronts different
sides different like outfits for each
corresponding location
planes tanks like it's the all-out war
conflict that I think uh I hold dear and
have always like been obsessed with
um and I think they're they're totally I
think they also took most of us by
surprise where we were talking like oh
how are they gonna handle this world war
one Vibe like are they going to be
gentle with it and it seems like you
know with like operations uh that mode
is
really unique how you kind of get a
little bit of heart and narrative
whether or not you lose or win that a
battle it kind of carries over into the
next one you feel like you made an
impact like to come you know to to segue
and combined more than one match uh I
think it's like a really engaging thing
and yeah just in general like I love
flying planes so it's it's also like
this is Battlefield as opposed to any
other shooter but pedal field I think is
for more patient people as far as like
what you're going to be playing right
because they're sometimes you're gonna
be covering large swaths of land and
nothing's gonna happen it's about that
lead up to the the battles and the
violence and the skirmishes but there
are also these moments where you're like
kind of you're sitting at this point
this Outpost you're covering this like
to defend it like in case someone flanks
and like you might be scouting and
you're not going to see anybody for 10
minutes but you'll still be doing
something kind of vital it's not going
to be like this moment-to-moment thing
like Call of Duty or this like fluid
kind of like fast-paced thing like
Titanfall but there are a lot more
situations when I feel like I'm part of
a bigger picture in Battlefield whether
I'm actually just like shooting another
person or not or firing a weapon at all
and that's what I like about Battlefield
and that's kind of like why I think
Battlefield 1 is my favorite one in a
while because that happens more often
than it did with like four Hardline or
anything right and it's got such
different yeah you kind of said
different varying levels of pace right
like if you are getting your ass handed
to you on the front lines hey there's a
plane you can hop into maybe you should
take up Scout and hit the hills like
that is a nice break because if there's
one thing I would have to say about Call
of Duty games like as much as I have
loved in the past but there is a moment
where you might be on a bad streak yeah
and it's like your heart can't handle it
and I'm just like I gotta take a break
uh I think that's like the something
that yeah Battlefield kind of does
differently yeah I don't know did you
play Battlefield much yet Scott you have
a chance I put a little bit of the
multiplayer I'm actually really excited
to try the campaign I like the way
they've structured it doing it sort of
like a series of non-linear vignettes
sounds really cool to me but yeah I mean
I think you guys really really nailed
you know hit the nail on the head that
it the multiplayer seems to embrace what
people or what what really distinguished
Battlefield from other Shooters in the
past I mean Hardline and four to maybe a
lesser extent were I think trying to
compete very directly with what Call of
Duty does and be a little bit more like
moment to moment you know instant
gratification twitch shooter and
Battlefield 1 is very much back to yeah
like very much slower pacing uh more
strategic options Vehicles larger Maps
longer modes all that kind of stuff that
makes it more strategic and and gives it
of just a different overall feel
compared to its competitors sure
um I don't know have you played uh have
you gotten this chance playing infinite
Warfare like do you play Call of Duty's
just yearly uh I don't know about yearly
but I've played
pretty much all of them since since
Modern Warfare like of the modern era I
think I'm not sure if I've actually
completely skipped any like I played a
bit of ghost and was like nah and I gave
up on ghosts yeah but yeah like I love
the Black Ops Trilogy um I don't think I
ever actually played uh like what was
last year's game it wasn't infinite
Warfare was the Black Ops 3 yeah okay
with two years ago the last um Advanced
Warfare Advanced Warfare yeah it was a
Sledgehammer Games first no I'm so I'm
sorry second my refer three with
Sledgehammer Games first call right the
whole like three Studio rotation thing
yeah it's a little hard to yeah track uh
because there's one every year but
Advanced Warfare I liked a lot too yeah
from what I've seen of infinite Warfare
regardless uh I'm I'm very excited I
think it's gonna be kind of different
kind of cool for Call of Duty um and it
is doing something very different
compared to Battlefield because it's
sticking with its you know instant
gratification die respawn over and over
you know kill death ratio Pursuit kind
of gameplay yeah that Call of Duty is
really known for and if you're if you're
listening to this on the podcaster or
earlier in the show apologies for
discussing infinite Warfare again but it
does have the rigs um which are kind of
like we said we're borrowing from Black
Ops 3 Specialists or like hero shooters
or mobile just these characters you can
kind of get used to which Titanfall
which get into in a second is also kind
of doing something with that but Call of
Duty like the the big thing right now
for me is the campaign because I'm
assuming it will just be like Call of
Duty campaigns are always like a nice
break from the multiplayer I do play
Call of Duty for the multiplayer I love
the campaigns like the Black Ops Trilogy
I totally agree did really cool things
with their storytelling yeah Black Ops 3
did some really weird stuff I don't want
to spoil anything but if you played
through that whole campaign it got weird
toward the end and I actually kind of
liked it for as like
I don't know kind of archaic or sorry
cryptic as some of it was but um yeah
Call of Duty obviously I think it goes
out saying there's not much to say as
far as like if you like last year's Call
of Duty and you had a lot you got like
you prestiged a few times you're
probably gonna like this one yeah for
you like if you're just if you want to
sit down play a match and you know just
if you're good at the like reflexes and
fast pace the Twitchy kind of gameplay
and like the rigs are new but those
ideas were kind of already there the
idea of these very specialized classes I
mean they've been diving deeper and
deeper into that style for a long time
so this is just sort of like the next
step the next iteration right yeah but I
think it could be cool I like I like the
space setting I'm excited about the
campaign I I mean I I enjoy the
campaigns for the same reason I watch
Like superhero movies right and they're
never gonna be you know works of art but
they're going to be like big and loud
and fun and enjoy experiencing them for
at least a little bit yeah you'll plow
through it in six hours and be like that
was cool and then just go play a bunch
of multiplayer like I don't know I
always have fun with those definitely
um I think it was
safe to do that it was a good move you
know like I that is kind of the next
progression like I think I'm I'm very
much over you know the idea of the near
future here on Earth like I like the
idea of you know like that's the next
step like colonizing planets and seeing
or being able to get more creative and
like showing and experimenting with
gravity and all that stuff like that was
a good direction sure
um to go on to like the third one there
was I want to like touch on Gears of War
4 because it's not the same it's not a
first person shooter but it's a shooter
and Gears of War kind of established
pretty much cover based third person
shooters at least raise the bar back in
2006 or 2007 when it first released I
reviewed it I gave it a seven out of ten
I liked it I think it's a really good
game I had some problems with it but you
know people hate me for it but I I
really have been I've still been playing
horde mode I've been playing multiplayer
dude horde mode is so good hormone is
really good it's a good class base um
and like again like it's not the same
vein as Titanfall 2 uh Call of Duty
infinite Warfare or uh Battlefield one
it's not a first person shooter but it
does have its own flavor obviously like
whether it's the third person
multiplayer that again they kind of
really like brought a new watermark for
um back when it released
I remember uh the first one being a nice
break from like my halo system link in
the garage days and just doing like
those extremely intense 2v2 uh
competitive matches were like it's down
to you another guy and you're just
launching sniper rifle shots like it's
still got that uh from what I've seen
and hearing you guys talk about that
yeah like those are good matches yeah
horde Mode's totally worth getting into
Jake Decker and I have still been
dabbling with it um if I had more time
to play that I definitely would uh the
class base five classes now if you have
all five people in each one of the
classes it's really fun
um and it's still like I think it's
better than three's horde mode which I
think they try to do too much with it
this they scale back where they needed
to but they also introduce cool things
that like add really good wrinkles to
the formula yeah definitely agree and I
think you're very right about
competitive multiplayer gears really
does movement and positioning in a way
that no other shooter really does like
the tactics of how you maneuver through
the battlefield is so unique to gears in
a way that's like kind of indescribable
but like the heft of the characters and
like the weight of cover and the way
that you employ cover it's not just
about like oh I'm gonna post up here and
fire it's like you're using cover
almost as like you're as like you're
charting a path right to get to your
enemies more so than like oh it's just
it's part of the shooting like it's
really kind of its own if you have to
think about it in its own way in like a
way that I'm not articulating well right
now no you're seeing like chess moves
almost like you know looking absolutely
okay let me jump over this cover and
like you know you know basically flank
someone what's the best way to get them
by surprise yeah I wonder if like I I'm
pretty sure like when they first
released the first Gears that was
totally intentional like they wanted
people to take advantage of that
magnetism but it took you a few hours to
get used to like you see people doing it
like people that were doing the uh the
flip with The Nasher like halfway
through going from cover to cover oh my
God that's possible I didn't dashing
yeah I didn't even know you could shoot
that like halfway through remember we
played that live stream last year or
yeah was that oh Ultimate Edition there
was some guy who was like coming down
the corridor just sliding around it was
it's heart gripping you're just like oh
yeah it's really creepy spooky and then
yeah like it I don't know like that
gears like still still feels great it
still is very much Gears of War they
didn't do a ton of new things with this
but like I think they did enough like
it's well worth going back to the series
for sure um you did a great documentary
on we did a Game Spot Studios and you
led that one up on uh kind of Rod
Ferguson like yeah back in the day like
the data she was the emotional core of
the series The Other Side of Gears that
isn't like the chainsaws and the blood
and gore and stuff because it's always
been there like there's always been that
side of Gears which is has always struck
me as very odd considering that you know
that the other half of it is so violent
and gory and like over-the-top masculine
chest bump whatever so it was always so
weird to me that those two things
existed within the same game and I just
decided to kind of dig into it and
fortunately for us Rob Ferguson is like
really forthcoming with his answers and
was really uh really generous with like
what he was willing to tell us about
that aspect of the game very well spoken
and uh like you know articulate guy for
sure
um but yeah last one Titanfall 2 that is
releasing next a week from Friday I
think it's this Friday no no Battlefield
one and Civ six or this Friday it's
weird because we've had all these ahead
of time yeah so 20 yeah so Battlefield
one and and civilization six are Friday
not that Civilization takes the shooter
and then Titanfall is a week after on
the 28th okay right yeah um it's hard to
keep track because we played all of them
at this point and like even the public
has like had Early Access to like
Battlefield and then now Call of Duty on
PS4 but Titanfall 2 is that last one we
want to talk about and this is the one I
think a lot of people are curious about
because the first one was a great game
it felt awesome it established this new
kind of trended Shooters of focusing on
movement and like Black Ops 3 Advanced
Warfare the Call of Duty's kind of took
over uh OverWatch some of the characters
like Lucio can like wall run and
everything and whatnot uh Hanzo can jump
over and Vault but that's so many
grappling hooks grappling hooks now
there's a lot of them this year big
thing Titanfall 2 introduces one but
um you and I have played a lot of it
after the review event Scott you've done
this makes sense of preview coverage on
Titanfall two and um
just like leaving aside anything else
despite how much like Battlefield 1
despite how like promising Call of Duty
has been in some respects I'm excited
about Titanfall 2 because I got burnt
out in the first one like a lot of
people it was always cranked up to 11
and I know after we did a few uh feature
videos on the development team at
respawned they said one thing they want
to do is kind of tune it back in certain
respects so it's not always cranked up
to 11. it sometimes goes down to like
five so you have these calmer moments
but and then it's that lead up like that
Battlefield that OverWatch lead up to
the action where you're kind of planning
things out and then your plan is going
to fall apart and you're gonna have to
react to that but also like you know I
don't want to focus too much on the
Titans because that's it's easy to do
with Titanfall 2 but obviously it's that
interplay between pilots and Titans but
also the fact that Titans are more like
Heroes now rather than these just two
things that you're gonna like deck out
with similar loadouts as the next person
like can you talk about how like Scorch
or Ronin or Northstar kind of like
playing into this new formula
yeah I I
those Titans are great I mean they're
really great but I would say for me at
least it's the mobility
um yeah I mean you said it like so many
games have kind of taken that path but
there is something about
Titanfalls especially their like map
layout of like chaining your parkour
moves in such a manner where it just
feels so empowering
um I just yeah that game is for me at
least it's like the the break from
Battlefield I think those two are like
actually probably the most diverse as
far as that Spectrum goes
um I get so anxious kind of just like
sprinting in Battlefield when I could
just be like grappling hook and wall
running and like ground sliding in
Titanfall it's hard to go back once
you've had those abilities in other
games it's like you just wanted yeah
because you start thinking about maps
and mobility in different ways you like
you see some you know vantage point like
I can just grab it no I can't this is
Battlefield but yeah Titanfall 2 like
it's it's crazy from what we played like
Scott I think you were the first one on
Gamespot to actually see all six Titans
in action Rob and I had done coverage
when it was still just Scorch and ion
now all three of us have played it with
six Titans and I ca I I don't want to
talk too much about it on my from my um
perspective because I'm reviewing it I'm
kind of in the middle of the review
right now but there's definitely a feel
that like not only do you want to know
the Titans so you know how to use them
but you also want to see a North star
know how to counter them you want to see
an eye on and know what not to do do
against an ion and like if you're a
pilot how to take them out but there's
definitely much more of like you said
earlier like a chess game Vibe like you
said with the gears but like even back
at E3 when I interviewed Vin zampella he
was saying like they were almost
inspired by fighting games which you
wouldn't think of because it's that
thing you want to know how to counter
all these characters but I don't know
what's your take on Titanfall 2 like
there are a lot of these minor additions
that are kind of you know they're trying
to set it apart from Titanfall one but
you know ideally they'd like people to
keep playing do you think it has the
legs do you think I don't know do you
think like Titanfall 2 is could be the
shooter the fall for a lot of people
I mean so the nice thing about
Titanfalls is I think it's positioning
itself so that it doesn't have to be the
shooter like it's offering something a
little bit different in that it does
have this combination of the you know
the high mobility of pilots and then
also like the high durability of of
Titans and like having to earn Titans
just the sort of the flow of combat and
the way that those two things marry in
in any given match uh it gives it a very
unique kind of pacing and feel
um and strategy that I think it's just
going to be a matter of taste for most
people so in terms of does it have
enough legs I don't know I think it
definitely is going to uh have more
longevity enjoy more longevity than the
original Titanfall I think it's it's
made some really smart changes that are
going to keep people invested for a
longer period of time the six Titans
being part of that
um I mean and also having the campaign I
think we'll keep we'll endear the game
to Gamers right I think more people will
want to hang on to the game once they
kind of have developed an understanding
of the universe and kind of connect with
the Titans and and hopefully that will
actually impact sort of the emotional
connection even in multiplayer
um so we'll see who knows I mean I I
really enjoyed all the time I've spent
with the game I don't know that it's
going to you know Dethrone Battlefield
especially now that we know that it's as
good as it is but I I could totally see
myself enjoying both and wanting to take
a break from one and play the other
because they offer such different things
yeah absolutely I mean like I was like
you know and just touching on what you
said like even the fact that it is a
good move that they've really
characterized these Titans because I'm
almost fairly certain to be honest like
that there will be a seventh Titan down
the road right like there will be that
reason to come back and check it out
even if it is for a few hours
um but I think that's that's like a neat
idea yeah yeah no I mean like we could
talk about all we want but like at the
very least this year has been awesome
for Shooters he had like battleborn
OverWatch Diablo Diablo Doom from
earlier in the year yeah and now you
have these or these four you have Gears
of War 4 is a third person shooter but
in terms of first person you have
Battlefield One Titanfall 2 Call of Duty
infinite Warfare all of which the ones
we haven't officially reviewed still
seem somewhat promising in a lot of
respects so uh yeah that is the shooters
releasing this fall so which one do you
think is for you Titanfall 2 Gears War 4
Call of Duty infinite Warfare or
Battlefield 1 let us know in the
comments below
Scott Butterworth unfortunately we have
to
bring someone on not replace you but
bring someone on to help supplement
finally get into Battlefield we're gonna
get way more into Battlefield one um
this is like our Miguel's opinion he
scored it and everything gave it a you
know nine out of ten we'll get into that
but Scott thanks so much absolutely guys
see you later see ya
that stream earlier I didn't I didn't
play well at all Battlefield 1. you got
killed quite a lot yeah highs and lows I
had some lows yeah on the end of that
stream but that game is super fun I just
there's always something to be said
about streaming a game like yep you kind
of play a little differently like I
would be playing it in at a much more
boring rate you know I'd be just like a
real campy with a sniper rifle if I was
getting my ass kicked on the ground like
we said but yeah it's a good game I've
definitely been getting my ass kicked in
Battlefield one I've had a few good
matches where I'm like I just I just
really help my team but Miguel
Concepcion you reviewed it for Game Spot
Miguel you uh you do a lot of freelance
work for us You're such you're working
from the office a lot lately you're
working on another review for us right
now which can't completely Call of Duty
you can't give an opinion but you're
working on the review for us
um you gave Battlefield 1 and 9 out of
ten you thought this game was superb as
a lot of us do so uh let's talk about it
broad Strokes why is this game like good
well I found that both the single player
and the multiplayer were both uh were
both excellent
um any kind of misgivings I had was or
anything that I thought were blemishes
was actually just coming down to the UI
especially in the multiplayer something
like not being able to exit the
multiplayer mode in between matches was
really surprising oh right yeah you
didn't notice that it was actually
easier you actually have to wait for the
next match to start before you can
actually get into the pause menu okay
um
and it came to the point where it was
even it was probably easier for me to
just like exit out of the game and then
relaunch it in order to get back into
the main menu dances like those kind of
like quality of life things they could
hopefully improve down the road like
right stuff and whatnot um yeah but what
do you think of the world war one
setting you think it kind of lends
itself well to this kind of game yeah I
thought it was almost long overdue you
know it was always whenever you see like
a feature about where should this
shooter franchise go
World War one is always like throwing as
sort of like a novelty suggestion or an
afterthought and like a ea and dice
uh thought they can just like jump
straight in into and like make it this
uh full-on AAA production and I just
thought they did a great job on it um to
the point that
you you could really see like where
where it can go with like with a
possible sequel or DLCs obviously when
you have like this four year long
conflict there's so many battles that
you can cover especially when even like
the campaign covers
mostly Wars from like the last two years
I mean battles from the last two years
of the war
um there were obviously many other
conflicts in the in the initial stages
yeah especially with this sort of the
Seesaw of the um the Germans and the
French on the Western Front that pretty
much took up like the first like not uh
six months yeah I do want to talk about
the uh progression because Rob you and I
you had like how many Battle Packs saved
up for the stream we did today six when
we opened it up yeah so the battle packs
are kind of like what like OverWatch
does with loot crates Call of Duty is
doing with its supply drops I think
they're called
um a lot of games do that now it's that
randomized items the like I think Mass
Effect three I remember was the first
one I remember on consoles kind of
introducing that random loot box
um weird segue for that but I'm kind of
interested in how the progression feels
for this like are you like unlocking new
like these World War One weapons pretty
often these new skins are like how does
the progression feel overall because
Call of Duty that's like the big draw
for me is the progression well it's
multi-layered not surprisingly
um the currency that you uh earn to buy
new weapons is these war bonds that you
get not through completing matches but
through leveling up so I want to make
that distinction okay uh there's also
these medals that sort of work like uh
challenges I mean uh in the classic
sense of challenges except in order for
it incentivizes you to come back weekly
because these challenges are essentially
temporary and you also have to
um make sure that you equip these Metals
so you actually get
uh you can actually like I guess for
like a better word grow these challenge
I mean grow these Metals yeah
um
I really appreciate how you can uh just
mold your your uh your your Your Arsenal
based on what you prefer
um because they it just has such a wide
spectrum of old school weapons
and um it's it will take like even like
the most hardcore player like weeks to
possibly get like you know the full
collection because I remember I was
playing as a support class earlier and I
know since the betas they and the alpha
they introduced the mortar I don't
believe that was there during the four
release yeah I don't think so yeah uh
and I like swap out the uh the other
possible items there for the mortar all
the time because I really like that kind
of makes the support class kind of
literally it's more support you're kind
of like bombarding these areas trying to
clear out these strongholds and I was
telling Rob earlier on the episode that
we I like Battlefield because there's
those moments where like you have to be
kind of patient to be good at
Battlefield right it's like about
placement on the it's literally about
placing on the battlefield
um and it's kind of about putting
yourself in the right situation to help
whether you're killing somebody or not
or you're just laying down suppressing
fire or you're kind of going this
flanking Mission like around to just get
this stronghold no one's paying
attention to
um does this feel like a kind of return
to form for the battlefield Series in a
lot of ways because I know like I think
four there's a lot of server issues when
like uh when was it four launched and uh
actually like hardline's kind of like
Scott was saying earlier it's still
there like a lot of it was more like
Close Quarter stuff like kind of trying
to combat these other modern military
Shooters but the battlefield ones seem
like kind of a return to tradition for
the battlefield franchise I'd say so
especially when as a contrast
um the the amount of work and
Imagination they put into the maps
um it just seems like actual maps that
you actual locations you could actually
visit in real life and I say contrast
because so many Maps so many of the maps
from um Hardline
feel or seemed like so symmetrical by
comparison
um obviously to be good at any kind of
like uh map in any multiplayer shooter
it just really comes down to just
memorizing the layout because
um in a given I think one of my favorite
Maps is this one in this French Farm
that shares uh shares like a couple
towns and half of the buildings are in
Ruins and you know you're gonna have
your share of of camping spots and just
um areas where you can snipe well
um
in all I really appreciate the maps
because it also led to me playing
outside my comfort zone
um trying out classes I usually don't
don't play with right
um I thought it was really like sniper
friendly and uh at least before the wide
release
my at-home cable connection with a
wireless router I was able to pull off
um sniper kills without any kind of lag
or any issues and I was very pleased
with that yeah because then there's like
that analog feel all these weapons
they're all their weapons there's that
you have to lead targets there's bullet
drop like especially like on sniper
rifle when you're shooting in long
distances but just like reloading oh
yeah you have to reload like not even
just the clip but let go of the zoo yeah
I mean for artillery things uh pieces
too yeah yeah definitely it's I don't
know there's definitely more it's
Battlefield so there's more weight to
the weapons here than Call of Duty it
feels like you're just like pointing
this like this like toy gun at people
but there's more weight to them it's a
little bit harder like uh a lot of times
they'll see a guy across a field and
I'll be using the trench submachine gun
and I'll be like I can't make shot by
the time I hit him once and do like 10
damage to him he's gonna have killed me
with whatever he's using
um and I actually picked my shots more
consistently I'm like paying more
attention to the situation than I would
in like a lot of other like Twitchy kind
of Shooters but there's also the thing
that you said that these don't feel like
Arenas to me these feel like actual
these feel like real places that people
just happen to be like playing a game on
I don't know and it does feel a lot more
like there are these kind of uh there's
this like natural feel to them like
organic I guess would be the term I mean
when you play something like Conquest
sometimes you think this side is
naturally the other team's side but that
never really happens because it always
keeps evolving like a team that can
dominate one side of the map by the end
of the match they end up dominating the
other side and you guys like organically
just switch areas
um one thing I always love about these
Battlefield Maps because it really
caters to teamwork
um I mean obviously you could you could
be like a lone wolfer a little bit but
you probably won't be that much of a you
won't really tribute much at the Grant
in the grand scheme of things yeah
definitely and it's kind of like some of
the maps play out as like these
individual skirmishes that are playing
at different capture points or like
houses or Farms like you said others
kind of like um Sinai desert I always
found that it was kind of like these
these uh outlying battles that are
playing into the central one of the town
it's kind of like cool and then there's
the one along the coast I forget the
name of it with the Dreadnought and the
castle
um and that's the one where it's FAO
Fortress FAO Fortress yes and that's the
one where it's kind of you know like
until the Dreadnought comes in
everybody's kind of attacking the castle
and the Castle's that stronghold that
it's kind of tough to take but then
there's the one up on the hill you can
take I don't know it's just kind of
thinking back on the stories that come
out of these matches like oh like I
couldn't take that castle but then all
of a sudden they came in the Dreadnought
I started bombarding it killed everybody
people came in the back and took it then
I capsized in the ship which you this
really happened to me I got smoked so I
know yeah I mean it's it's kind of nice
to
a little worrisome when like you know
they introduced the Behemoth blimp yeah
oh my God this thing's just gonna wreck
shop however the balancing of it seems
to be pretty safe like
you know if if it is a landslide match
and it's 20 minutes long and you're just
you know having not these behemoths you
kind of know halfway through that your
team's going to lose sure but now it's
like okay even if we are winning we have
to worry about a tank and that that is
your automatic sense of drive for
teamwork is like we have to take out
that I'm sorry a train we have to take
out the train or whatever Behemoth it is
in order to like ensure that we will win
and the the matches have been so tight
like I won one uh as a train um
artillery
um conductor
like we won by three tickets uh it was
exhilarating like which essentially is
three seconds for those who haven't
played right yeah right and that's it's
cool when the behemoths come in how they
switch like your role like if you're in
a plane before the Behemoth uh before
like an Airship comes in you're doing
strafing runs you're bombing tanks
you're dog fighting with other planes
you're maybe like again strafing runs or
bombing like a capture point to help
your foot soldiers get in there the
Airship comes along it's pretty much
like you're one of the first lines of
Defense to take out the gondolas
underneath it that have all the machine
guns and dropping bombs and whatnot
um and that's one thing I like how these
matches can like you said the scenario
switches so fast like you could be a
scout and you're like aiming across this
field trying to take out people that are
trying to cross it to get the capture
point you go into this house next door
just becomes close quarters battles and
you are having a tough time with just
your sidearm against shotguns
um I do want to talk quickly about the
campaign because that was like one thing
that nobody really played before like
you came out there's no beta or Alpha
from what I understand but what did you
think of the campaign like as far as
again making use of the world war one
setting or just overall quality like how
fun was it well it's presented in this
Anthology format where it almost comes
off where the it seems like
there are all these um it could have
each segment could have been written by
a different writer right each one has
their own tone each main character kind
of has their own personality and
motivations
um overall it just really it it was
thoughtful and heartfelt
um it's it it really is a contrast with
the previous Battlefield campaigns where
by comparison it actually really
accentuates how the prior campaigns
especially with Battlefield 3 and 4. how
those were just like these persistent
powder kegs where each each
chapter felt like it had something to
prove and it always had to felt some
obligation to keep like your your pulse
up this one it's you know there's like
this ebb and flow with you know
um like say with like the this tank
Mission the camaraderie with that that
you quickly gain from you know meeting
all these strangers in this tank
um there's this really heartfelt one in
um where this uh veteran it looks like
he's he's like seven years old and it's
like the 1950s and he's reflecting on
his time
um
uh when he was protecting his twin
brother in this mission in in the Alps
yeah
yeah I know it's I mean like I'm excited
to play it because for all intense
purposes it seems like it's making use
of the world war one setting more than
maybe the multiplayer in some respects
as far as the storytelling goes and that
is the appeal to me because of the heart
that appears to be there I mean I will
also say that I love that many of the
settings aren't just reusing assets from
the the multiplayer map I mean some
games can get away with that but I
really I really thought that the that
the art team really did a great job in
just really mixing things up and there
was one particular map that actually
looked like some 19th century painting
with just these really really yellow and
orange like um afternoons
um I don't want to spoil the setting
because sometimes just even seeing these
levels for the first time is a pleasant
surprise sure yeah well anyway that is
uh Battlefield one Miguel Concepcion
thanks so much for coming on talk about
it I'll give it a nine out of ten your
review is up video review as well as
written on Gamespot I think it's still
promo to top of the page so you can go
read that right now if you're interested
in Battlefield 1 and checking it out but
let us know what you think about the
game in the comments below once you get
to play it all right Miguel thanks so
much for coming on we appreciate it
you're welcome we'll let you uh let you
off right now and then we're gonna bring
on Justin haywald to talk about a little
thing happening Thursday that we just
found out today
Red Dead
two whatever it's gonna be called
Rockstar Games that's it I did okay
we'll get more into it when he comes
down but uh yeah we gotta actually like
after the uh this segment we're gonna
kind of try to you know talk about I
think we're like gonna pimp a little
stream we're doing Thursday morning me
and you and Jake are gonna come in I
think awesome cool yeah we're gonna be
playing Red Dead Redemption just I think
Jake's got to save a little bit into the
game a couple hours yeah
um and we're gonna be playing that right
before the trailer releases and
everything yeah it's pretty great I mean
that I mean that thing's on Xbox now
yeah like or Xbox One excuse me
um I actually never finished Red Dead
like a jerk head I've been working on it
um and this just gives me even more
drive to have it completed hello Justin
Justin haywald as usual comes in with
high amounts of energy to the lobby
we're here to shoot some people right
you guys have been shooting people all
day I was watching in the background but
there's a delay oh yeah so I it's all
right I didn't know that it was my turn
so the other day we got a little teaser
image from Rockstar it was uh kind of
this red background with the Rockstar
logo kind of we've been hearing there
were rumors circulating back around E3
right that we might be seeing a Red Dead
Redemption remaster or a new Sequel and
now we kind of know based on the image
that we saw today which shows I think it
was like six people coming over the
hilltop with that same background kind
of or a group of people
um it's clearly Red Dead 2 or SQL or
whatever Red Dead Redemption 2 Red Dead
Redemption 2 now we know uh Thursday
there's gonna be the trailer dropping
we're doing a viewing party I was just
talking to Rob about it
um so we just wanted to talk today about
what we want from Red Dead Redemption 2.
you played Red Dead Redemption
extensively I'm assuming you beat it but
I did Redemption I never played Red Dead
Revolver I did a lot actually weirdly uh
it was on I played on the original Xbox
like third person shooter um there's I
think there's actually a lot of people
that don't it's
it is it's kind of it's tough I mean it
was really fun though I mean there were
like these boss fights on these missions
there were different these Legendary
Weapons you get as you're playing
through it and it's so weird that it
became Red Dead Redemption because
there's like eons or like just so
different experiences
um but Red Dead Redemption uh Justin
when's the last thing you play have you
played it recently at all I played it
when it came out but I mean that's a
game that sticks with you the story in
that game is it's still I would say one
of my favorite games of all time you
have those those Quiet Moments When in
other games when you're just kind of
going across an empty plane like when
you're just going across the world it's
boring but in here it's like it felt
like there was so much life and then you
have those musical cues like they just
come up and you're like oh I'm going
into Mexico or that part near the end of
the game when you just like you're
riding down the hill and you have the
music playing over it it's like
emotionally that still touches me like I
still get chills thinking about it yeah
if there wasn't that bass that rumbling
bass it's like
holy God does your you're just yeah
you're exactly right you're just kind of
wandering a really Barren desert but
it's it's exciting and the characters
are so so memorable like John Marston as
a character like he he nailed that
perfectly that spaghetti western
character who who's kind of on both
sides of the law who's who's an
anti-hero but someone you also relate
with and someone you want to to do well
so when you want to win it's like a bad
dude trying to be good and uh and then
he's forced to be bad again because of
what the government comes and he's like
trying to take his land what is the
storyline because I know his family's in
trouble too but I I don't know I'm
trying to remember what actually I love
that game but I had so much escapes me
it's such a big game every now and then
I know oh no no sorry the government
comes back looking for his ex cohorts
from his gang they're trying to hunt
them down because they've been active
again so then they ask him to go like I
thought the government came down and
asked me to kill a lot of rabbits
because I did a lot of that right
that's well that's also like yeah I mean
when you look at Grand Theft Auto 5
obviously this game was uh red Arena red
Devil's Redemption was 2010 if I'm not
mistaken uh Grand Theft Auto 5 being
2013 but three years before that there
wasn't as much to do in Red Dead
Redemption obviously that's gonna happen
when like Grand Theft Auto 5 comes out
three years after it but I remember they
just nailed that setting like you said
that Jose Gonzalez song that plays when
he's coming over the hill in Mexico it's
like step in front of a runaway it's
such a that's such an awesome moment
like the sun and like I saw it when the
sun was going down my friend saw was
coming up and like stuff some people saw
it at night when you go in yeah but it
really nailed that story and that's what
I'm wondering where Red Dead Redemption
2 is going to go from there because Red
Dead Redemption for as large of a game
as it was it's pretty intimate personal
thing it's John Marston confronting the
people he used to roll with when they
were like robbing trains and Banks and
whatnot but it's like a Revenge tale
um I don't know that we should spoil the
ending I mean it's been a while no
please don't but now that Red Dead
Redemption 2 is on the way out like this
will be the latest chance for the first
time for people yeah I mean it's bad
backwards compatible on Xbox one right
that's we're gonna be playing on
Thursday I think but yeah go play this
game because it I'm wondering how
connected two will be to it because it
shows a handful of people like I don't
have people like started looking at the
faces yet on the in the image I was
about to kind of see the faces yeah you
could kind of see the um whoever it is
first like you know the center uh
character it didn't look like John
Marston uh I thought it kind of did I
thought it didn't unless it was like a
prequel or something like we don't know
when it's have they there's no details
about it aside from like this is Red
Dead Redemption 2. it's not gonna
there's there are no confirmed details
but speculation is running that it that
could be a prequel so there are seven
people there's one in the middle um his
hair looks shorter see yeah and it just
gets I mean okay so it's coming out fall
2017 but it looks like it's got like
Magnificent Seven Vibes or like hateful
eight if you like that I don't know but
I'm but they also said they're gonna
have like a new online experience so
that kind of lends itself you know like
maybe it's gonna be like I'm assuming
it's gonna be GTA online with in the
wild west and it's gonna come out months
later and then they're gonna keep
introducing new DLC and despite the fact
that I haven't played it in two years a
ton of people still play GTA online and
like I do yeah I go back all the time
sometimes if you come in early in the
morning I just see you playing that it's
actually I just saw you playing that
today when you should have been working
no I'm just kidding I'm being a jerk not
to segue too much onto like GTA online
but I for what it is I think it's a
pretty fantastic
segment to Grand Theft Auto 5. like
where it's like just having seen when it
first came out to now it's pretty wild
what like you open up
that game now and it's just like all
this activity going on in the open world
like now there are biker gangs I don't
know if you've even seen any of this new
update it is wild like basically you
just step out your door and it's just
chaos not I mean which you know is kind
of fitting for Red Dead Redemption right
like if you can imagine like being in
your own gang and hidden
the uh old west but that that this the
success that they found the GTA online
like there's no way they can't bring
that idea over to Red Dead Redemption
but part of me also doesn't want that
like that it's a cool idea and GT
online's done it so well but the thing
that stood out for Red Dead for me was
that single player experience something
you're not going to be able to get in a
GTA outline as cool as that is and with
GTA online they also kind of skipped all
of the single player DLC we got Promises
of more of the story right and I I don't
want them to sacrifice that element for
just the the thing that's going to 100
be successful and 100 be fun like I
still want that emotional core of a
single player experience after seeing
the teaser image uh here's what I
thought about GTA 5 introduced you know
Franklin Michael and Trevor you can swap
between them on the Fly how ambitious
would it be to be able to swap between
seven people in the wild west I doubt
and that's what I want I don't know how
possible that is in this day and age to
be able to because that it's seamless in
GTA 5 you just you fly up
and at a certain point in the game once
you unlock all three people meet them
you just fly up go to Franklin over in
this part of La sorry um Los Santos zoom
out go back into Michael do his like
midlife crisis stuff go to Trevor just
be Psycho who was in a police chase and
they're all like different flavors right
like again Trevor is doing this police
chase stuff Michael's head going like
this midlife crisis but also trying not
to get into like too much bad [__] and
then you have like Franklin who himself
is trying to escape the bad stuff to be
a better person kind of like John
Marston I guess but that's ambitious I
know seven different people that'd be
awesome like to be able to zoom out like
go to this person who's like a robber
and then like like all just watching all
the people come together like this
dude's a sheriff maybe but I mean
obviously the teaser image implies that
they're kind of a gang they're walking
toward with each other toward a camera
but I'm I'm Ann knowing Rockstar I'm
sure they'll be very distinct characters
I'm kind of looking forward to seeing
how they deal with that structure
because Red Dead Redemption for intense
purposes was just Grand Theft Auto put
into the wild west and I would assume
they would try to like take GTA 5's
formula and kind of evolve into
something new so that's what I was
hoping because I was hoping to actually
make use of this ensemble cast or even
make that Co-op like that you could play
that single player experience and each
person takes on a different role and
maybe you can swap out between different
ones but that's you're all playing
together but in a story yeah where they
go from here like with the world because
I mean the wild west it was uh Armadillo
Texas you start off in and then you're
kind of going around Texas over the
border to Mexico what if this is like a
Tombstone Arizona thing or like uh I
don't know what kind of do you guys have
any ideas for settings they'd want to
see it in or like what if it's I'd like
to see some snow Yeah I was gonna say
what if it's like a hateful eight kind
of like the Badlands of Montana kind of
feel well you could do like Northern
Arizona right like even up there yeah
parts of the Southwest have like
different climates than just desert and
stuff that'd be awesome yeah I'd like to
see them kind of because
um I mean aside from them when you go
into the marshes uh like those swamps
and whatnot and like some of the fields
in the Red Dead Redemption it was all
very just desert feeling
um obviously that makes sense with the
wild west but I'm kind of looking
forward to seeing where they're gonna
set it and like what because like what
maybe like they'll take an actual place
and fictionalize it kind of like Mafia
three dead or GTA 5 all the grand the
thought I was dead or Watch Dogs 2 said
in San Francisco would be cool to see
that Gold Rush era
what if what if Rockstar a year after
did a better San Francisco 100 years
before no I'm not implying anything yeah
earthquake San Francisco yeah like oh
before the the fires and whatnot too
yeah but like what era right what like
time period yeah yeah because that's
like a big deal I mean like again
there's probably I need to look into
like seeing how many people like have
dissected the stuff going on but right
this gang looks cool this one's got a
trench coat on the bowler hat then one
dude looks like he's got a long like
double barrel shotgun another one's got
a huge gun draped of a stroller the
Manus got a rifle I don't like
this like the fact that they're just the
first image they show off is all seven
people I have to imagine like Justin
said maybe it's I don't know maybe the
new online experience is a co-op thing
or maybe like I said you're swapping I
hope to God you can swap between seven
people like how you would not get bored
with that game that would be seven
people too much I know people would be
too many people want this is wishful
thinking I don't Rockstar can do what
they want I'm sure they'll pull it off
but if I was designing this game and I
was like dictator in the development
Studio I'll be like all right or they
would be able to swap on the Fly between
how many people do we want like seven
like no really seven get out you're
fired no they couldn't find me I'm a
dictator no but I'm saying you would
fire other people oh we can't do that
and he's like well you're fired yeah be
better no just kidding uh I don't know
like sure this is weird that the teaser
image itself is like seven people like
they have there has to be something to
that like it's the first image they're
showing off Thursday at 11 A.M eastern
time is when the trailer's dropping at 8
A.M our time we're gonna be in early in
the morning playing Red Dead Redemption
at like 7 A.M uh into it playing that
for an hour watch the trailer and then
we're gonna get together and talk about
it afterward that trailer is gonna be
sick what do you think the first shot of
the trailer is going to be a sunrise no
a sunset I'm saying Tumbleweed and then
with a whistle yeah definitely whistle
and then uh and then a boot
Stagecoach camera underneath the
stagecoach like it rides over Dusty
train robbery with seven people that are
swapping between I'm not letting it
now imagine if like one of the last
shots does show like that thing like
zooming out and then back into someone
else they wouldn't do that with us I'm
assuming it's gonna be a pretty
cinematic trailer and not yeah it's not
gonna be gameplay because right now it's
fall 2017. who knows when it's gonna
actually release but that's the
tentative uh placeholder right now I
just want more customization because G
especially after GTA and how you're able
to just customize every little thing in
that game and I loved the costumes and
things you could unlock in Red Dead
Redemption like imagine being able to
paint your state like trick out a
stagecoach like crazy like get crazy
horses and just paint them however you
want yeah like I want coats of paint I
want to paint my horse
I I love the idea
someone zebra stripe horse there's some
uh some predictions in the chat uh
Diablos X or Diablo sex I apologize if
I'm butchering that but you said the
seven people in the picture could be the
people you fight against maybe a gang
you're going after so who knows bosses
um super mega loser said maybe they're
all one person but dressed differently
superimposed next to each other
um it could be a wrecking yeah someone
was saying third guy from the left looks
like John we don't have the image up
right now but it kind of does actually
he's wearing that same kind of almost
bowler hat with like a vest on but again
like you get different outfits as John
but yeah I don't know like needless to
say I mean people are kind of like
making fun of everybody for hyping it up
but what if this is tied in to HBO and
this is all gonna sync up with Westworld
uh yeah like robots and whatnot yeah
yeah so this is gonna be the playable
version of Westworld that's that's how
they're financing it because Rockstar
you know they probably don't have a lot
of money they these their games are
never very successful all right so do
you know okay so you're telling me that
the game is just repeating the same day
like Majora's Mask you'll relive it each
day you're trying to figure out however
you're going to be like Majora's Mask
and so do I I do yeah but if Majora's
Mask gets swap between seven people so
needless to say the teaser image has got
us all excited try not to Hype it up too
much but I don't know it's Rockstar it's
always exciting because they're so
secretive most of the time uh fall 2017
a tentative placeholder release date
Thursday 11 A.M eastern time the
trailer's gonna be up here at Gamespot
come back uh tune in probably starting I
don't know what time early in the
morning Pacific time like seven trailers
dropping at eight eight Pacific so maybe
like we'll be here we'll be here early
we'll get some coffee we'll bring in
like bagels or something we'll be
playing Red Dead Redemption on Xbox One
the backwards compatible version I think
Jake and you both have saves somewhere
in the game so we're gonna We're not
gonna start from the beginning and do
all that ranch work and whatnot but
right uh yeah so I'm looking forward to
the trailer that'll be up and then we'll
right after that convene again with a
bunch of people Justin I don't know if
you're gonna be here but you're gonna
wear a cowboy hats
dude yeah you'll know sick walking down
2nd Street in San Francisco clinking
along the sidewalk it wouldn't be that
far off yeah all right so Red Dead
Redemption 2 the trailer is coming out
let us know what you want to see in the
sequel to the 2010 title let us know in
the comments below
man I'm excited for that oh that's gonna
go yeah I'm excited it's uh Red Dead
Redemption I didn't get to play until
like a year after I think 2010 released
and that was my I don't want to give
away my age
um I was a in 2010 I was a six-year-old
no just kidding uh no I was a freshman
in college so I didn't like get much
chance to play video games that first
semester I think I like released right
around then so then I got back into that
and like Halo Reach I think was another
game that came out right around then
um yeah you didn't touch on the
controversy that seemed to sprung up
whether this should be Red Dead 3 or Red
Dead Redemption 2 because everyone was
like no don't call this Red Dead
Redemption 2. it's gonna be this is Red
Dead three something else red dead
because there are so many r words you
could use Red Dead Revolver and then Red
Dead Redemption uh Revival yeah
Revisited attribution Red Dead
redhead Reeboks Red Dead robot
attack again Red Dead robot
I want yeah oh man you guys have plans
for us a week aside from work or Red
Dead Red Dead Romance I'm just gonna
think of our all the r words he's gonna
keep rattling those off Rob what are you
doing this week weekend it's only
Tuesday I don't know if you have weekend
plans yet I want to play Battlefield
campaign man yeah me too yeah I'm really
looking forward to that I'm gonna I
might be playing a little more Call of
Duty um you and I are going down to La
Friday for a pretty cool project talk
about that later on down the road
um a lot of games coming out later this
week Civ six oh man [__] I'll be playing
a lot of sip six I already have I'm
gonna play Civ six
um anyway Red Dead rubbers okay on that
note everybody as always thank you for
joining us whether you're listening on
iTunes whether you are kind of like
watching us right now in our Delirious
state or whether you're watching us on
YouTube gamespot.com as always much
appreciated we will see you hopefully
Thursday we're watching The Red Dead
Redemption 2 trailer we're gonna talk
about it play Red Dead Redemption but
anyway until next week see you then Red
Dead ribbed
foreign
[Music]